[Musique]
le mexique a donné au monde des fruits
extraordinaire
piment la tomate et l'avocat l'avocat
est particulièrement riche en bons
lipides
il contient beaucoup de vitamines et des
substances antioxydantes
il contribuerait efficacement à la
réduction du cholestérol à une
prévention des maladies
cardiovasculaires et du diabète de type
2 donc ça c'est la merde tous deux
avocats et le site noyau là et vient
toutes les nouvelles avocate une variété
comme assez xetra mais à celle de
l'avocat originale du mexique s'appelle
comment awa catriona à ouaga iv ça veut
dire quoi à wasquehal
ça veut dire cette phrase on va dire
testicules en amateur ça pulse un peu a
dit à des gens qui disent je voulais pas
le faire tu vas tout cas je voulais tu
le feras mauvaise voie
[Musique]
depuis des milliers d'années les
mexicains consomme de l'avocat tous les
jours en très grande quantité mais voilà
les prix flambent c'est bien trop cher
la faute à l'exportation
les meilleurs avocats du mans pousse
depuis toujours sur leur terre d'origine
de plus en plus populaires partout dans
le monde
mangés crus guacamole l'avocat c'est le
fruit parfait sa culture au mexique par
contre est loin de l'aisne
le michoacan ses montagnes ses lacs ses
forêts de pins et de chênes l'un des
poumons du mexique m c'est de cet état
que provient la plus grande partie des
avocats consommer en amérique du nord
mais pour produire de plus en plus
d'avocats cette forêt on la brûle tout
ce matin et j'étais des forêts
originellement ils sont en train de
transformer peu à peu ils vont commencer
à planter enlever tous les harkis sont
déroulés ils vont commencer à planter
des avocats
[Musique]
rossi lou alvarez et pépiniéristes
forestiers son métier c'est reboiser son
hacienda est une immense pépinière de
pain et de sapins ils savent qu'il faut
déjà pour vivre pour respirer procès
luis a commencé il ya 25 ans il
s'agissait de protéger cet autre trésor
du michoacan le papillon monarque celui
qui migrent tous les printemps vers le
nord-est des etats-unis et du canada et
qui l'hiver se réfugier dans les
montagnes du michoacan je n'ai fait
beaucoup de restauration des forêts
naturelles
ici beaucoup de plantations commerciales
maintenant ils sont en train d'exploiter
le forez l'éliminer totalement pour
faire des plantations des avocats parce
que l'avocat
sailor verte lors vers cette folie le
menacent directement
il s'est entouré d'une grande forêt mais
de chez lui on voit de plus en plus des
espaces déboisés comme celui-ci procès
luiz ne veut pas trop être vu dans ces
zones sensibles alors c'est son
majordome monde de la grogne qui nous y
mène et demie grenelle a ra keitel rona
qui randonnent 30 hectares de coupe et
bientôt tout sera brûlé labour et est
prêt à recevoir des petits avocatier
comme le champ voisin
en face on voit bien le processus la
jeune plantations en bas plus haut des
avocatiers de 2 et 3 ans et tout en haut
ils ont dix à la forêt qui reste au
sommet bientôt aura disparaît et la
combler ya zéro
il n'y a pas si longtemps il y avait une
source la bâtiment de la grenade a
disparu elle alimentait le lac de syrah
wayne plus de forêts plus d'eau le
climat change il pleut moins dit
l'ingénieur forestier de la région
militaire pologne nous perdons près de
1000 hectares par an dit-il dans les
quatorze municipalités du centre du
michoacan en plus la culture de l'avocat
exige beaucoup d'eau les villages
commencent à se battre pour de l'eau oui
il s'agit d'une guerre de l'eau à cause
de l'avocate lors vers tout le monde en
veut à commencer par les canadiens et
surtout les américains de gros
consommateurs chaque année pour le super
bowl pour cette seule journée le mexique
export pour 200 millions de dollars
d'avocats pour faire du guacamole à
déguster devant les téléviseurs les
marchands mexicain et américain
d'avocats ne lésine pas sur la pub
une publicité pendant le super bowl
coûte entre 5 et 12 millions de dollars
alors depuis cinq ans c'est la ruée sur
les bonnes terres celle qui se trouve
entre 1500 et 2500 mètres d'altitude que
le gel n'atteint pas là où il ya des
forêts tout est bon pour récolter deux
fois par an cet or vert
oui j'utilise pesticides fongicides de
fertilisants mais l'exportation il ya
des contrôles dans les producteurs des
avocats et un contrôle qui peut pas
utiliser certains produits chimiques ans
et l'est où sa soeur jusqu'à la
révocation aux états unis savent ce
qu'ils venaient d'une certaine en dehors
mais il ya trop de nouveaux venus on ne
sait d'où avec de l'argent beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup j'en pense pas
vraiment d où vient de l'argent avec
lequel ils achètent les terres ils font
les plantations
c'est un peu du tueur stis à cet argent
pourrait venir de ça peut devenir du
trafic de drogue ça peut devenir de
kidnapper preuve ya pas de preuve du
tout mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est
pas des gens de la région
ce n'est pas l'image que l'industrie
veut donner à l'étranger
la culture de l'avocat des milliers
d'emplois permanents et temporaires
ça c'est pour le consommateur canadien
mais sur place le programme d'arrachage
de plantations illégales que nous
devions documenté a été interrompue à
cause de plâtre la situation est hors de
contrôle
les producteurs légitime savent qu'ils
ont un gros problème posé luiz devrait
travailler avec eux
[Musique]
le jour de notre arrivée au mexique sept
travailleurs engagés pour arracher des
plantations illégales ont été battus et
exécutés tout ce qu'on sait c'est que la
plantation de 200 hectares appartenu à
un narcotrafiquant notoire
l'une des victimes est le gendre
d'alicia nonies la cuisinière de rossi
luis qui nous a préparé le guacamole mon
attachement - akka vacances y était
c'est une tragédie
sept personnes de la même famille son
gendre raphaël avait 23 ans son épouse
maria lisbeth reste seule avec trois
enfants dont une petite fille de trois
mois
[Applaudissements]
les six autres victimes étaient des
cousins dont certains avaient aussi de
jeunes enfants
la rage de l'avocat fait des morts au
michoacan
personne ne croit qu'on trouvera un jour
les assassins
[Musique]
à